The big cover up
Where I come from
there was always been a need for women who
take a stand.
As a child in Afghanistan,
I used to watch my mother read the news on
public TV.
But when the Mujaheddin fighters came into
power
in the early nineties
the acting Communist government
started to make admissions to the Islamist
opposition.
They ordered all female anchors to wear a
headscarf on TV.
My mother refused to do this.
Political conflicts shouldn’t be settled
over the rights of women.
Against all odds and the pressure of the government
she went on-air, headscarf free.
Until today her act of resilience
inspires me immensely.
This is one of the reasons
that I chose journalism as a profession.
If you take a stand
you can have an enormous impact on society.
Headscarf or no headscarf,
you should decide for yourself
what you want to wear.
I'm Waslat Hasrat-Nazimi
and I work at DW.